hey welcome to day two of building an
Alexis kill the the live stream so for
anybody that was here alexinnz gonna
start talking back to me here let me
shut her off for anybody that was on
yesterday welcome back for anybody
that's new welcome glad to have you I'm
gonna start today we're gonna just jump
right in I'm gonna start with a recap
quickly of what we did yesterday
and then I'm gonna get into the topics
for today and we're all we'll start with
a quick introduction to the Alexis
skills kit CLI and then we will talk
about the Alexa skills kit sdk 2.0 a
little bit and then we will jump into
building our project which i've got some
ideas on and I'm hoping to get some
feedback from all of you on the the
direction for it so this will hopefully
be an opportunity to to work together to
build our skills so it's not completely
scripted I didn't want this to just be a
live cast of an Alexa development course
I did one of those so if that's what
you're looking for you can just check
that out on free code camp but yesterday
what we discussed is the the things that
you'll need to start developing Alexa
skills and really it's two things you
need to knit for an account you need an
Amazon developer account which you can
get at developer amazon.com and you need
an AWS account and then we also talked
yesterday about the the basics of how a
skill works and covered it you know
basically it's it's Jason that's being
passed back and forth between the Alexa
service and the skill service which is
the backend it processes the requests in
responds to what
users are asking for and then we Dovan a
little bit into the developer portal and
looked at setting up a basic skill and
talked a little bit about AWS lambda and
how that works and then we built a
really super simple skill that was just
returning Jason and I kind of fumbled
around on that which is a good lead-in I
suppose to our topic today which is
using the the SDK it makes life a whole
lot simpler and that's what we're gonna
talk about but as I as I jump into it I
have an idea that I wanted to put out
there for everybody so I'm thinking that
maybe we for the example skill that
we're gonna be building maybe we
actually build a live skill and I talked
to the guys at free code camp and
checked out the Alexa skills corridor
and didn't see a skill for free code
camp so I thought maybe we could try to
build a skill for free code camp but I
would definitely need all of your help
and it's a little bit risky because I'll
be very much going off script but if if
you guys are up for it I will give it a
try and we've got a few other people
from my team here online that are in the
the live chat that will be able to
answer questions and stuff yeah I can
I'll make the font bigger here for see
that that question there let me see
hopefully that's a little bit better you
got a couple of people online that can
help out with any questions so if you
have questions just please go ahead and
post those in the live chat and I'll be
looking at those as I'm going through
this and then Karthik who is in the live
chat also Karthik if you're on maybe you
could just like post hi he is he's
available to answer your questions in
the chat also and Ken
and our pita I think they're all online
so they can answer questions so please
go ahead and ask any questions that you
have as as we're going and I'll I'll
pause from time to time to look at the
questions and try to answer them is as
best that I can
so let's um yeah let's get into it so
today we are going to so I got rid of
everything from yesterday we just did an
overview and we're gonna start fresh
today
and we're gonna start fresh using the
the Alexa skills kit CLI and if you are
I'm not going to install that and
everything in in this live cast but it's
basically a command-line tool that you
can use to build skill projects and
deploy skill projects and if you if you
google ask CLI there is a Quick Start
Guide and there's a couple of tutorials
that I did a while back actually down
here too and if that if you're just
getting the CLI installed and configured
that you can follow and if you go to the
the dabba lab YouTube channel there is I
think these ones that pop up these are
kind of old so you might go to
youtube.com slash data lab and there's
some newer tutorials or skill templates
comm actually has a tutorial also for
getting the the Alexa skills kit CLI
installed the prerequisites what you'll
need is you'll need to have no js'
installed you can install this on if
there's just an NPM package so you can
install it on Windows Linux or Mac
working on a Mac for all these but the
commands all work the same and you will
after you've installed it you'll
configure it you'll initialize it to
work with your accounts that we
look at setting up yesterday so your AWS
account and your Amazon developer
account and it's pretty straightforward
the the install process so again I'm not
going to go through it but if you have
any issues you can look at the tutorials
that are on the dev left channel and
leave any comments there and we can help
you through it if you run into anything
okay
yeah so with our but also from data lab
is on that's great thanks for a Pathan a
Targa okay the the fonts better okay
awesome
all right well let's let's get into it
so like I said I'm going to try to build
a skill for free code camp and I want to
so this is gonna be you know a real real
live demo of how the process works
but what what we generally start with is
is going through the high level what we
want the skill to do so I'm going to do
that with everybody and we'll start with
free code camp that's what we're gonna
call the skill for right now the name
and I usually start by defining how the
skill will be launched so launch phrases
and in the the Alexa world when you're
launching a skill we talked yesterday
about the invocation names so we're
going to use for our example school
we're going to use free code camp as the
invocation name so we would say
minimally something like Alexa open free
code camp but we also might provide a
directive or an utterance something like
Alexa ask free code camp camp what
articles like type articles are
published medium and that was one of the
things that they said they'd like to see
is a way for users to ask Alexa about
articles that are published on the the
free code camp medium channel and maybe
we'll also have something like Alexa ask
free code camp okay I don't know any any
thoughts on what we can do what would
you need some need some feedback from
you guys here what do you think we
should be we should be doing how how
should this skill work everybody is part
of the the project team now so let's
let's put some ideas out there post it
in the in the chat let's hear what you
got
come on something free code camp
as free code camp what live streams are
scheduled don't know if we can do that
but we'll put it in here ah that's a
good one Karthik LexA asked recode camp
what programming languages are popular
what else anything else what's in your
curriculum would it what are the last
few videos published that's a good one
we can get that from the YouTube API API
I think ok we can be at we can be adding
to this I'm gonna leave it at that for
right now
but if anybody thinks of anything else
let's put it on here
minimally it'll just go on our wish list
for future functionality but we'll we'll
start with this so this is when we're
planning a project generally where it
starts we just think about how the user
might interact with the skill from the
very beginning and the very beginning is
launching the skill and so we just
brainstorm some ideas like this and then
the next thing we do is we do a like a
really simple interaction example
[Music]
and the way that we write it out is
something like this we would say like
the user would say let's see we'll start
with them the simplest one so Alexa up
in free code camp and then Alexa is
gonna respond with something like Hello
yeah we do need a multi turn dialogue
too
so somebody that was your idea then
kinda I'm sure I'm killing your name but
come up with an idea for a multi turn
dialogue I think I think you're right
well I want to try to get that in here
so what do you got come up with
something that that we can use go out to
free code camp org and poke through the
site if you got a second and come up
with something that you think we can use
this an example again this is we're all
working together on this this project so
Alexa is going to respond with hello
welcome you the free code camp skill and
I can tell you about articles recent
medium particles
or scheduled live streams and I'm making
this up as I go so if anybody has a
better a better idea then please post it
and we'll we'll update this and we can
change it as we go too so and then the
we'll ask a question will prompt the
user what would you like something like
this and then the user will say what's
been posted on medium
and then Alexa will say something like
here are the most recent by posts and we
don't want to have a list of like
everything that's been posted obviously
because the user would be just sitting
there for hours and maybe if we wanted
to get fancy we could let the user say
tell me the the next five posts or
something like that but right now we'll
keep it simple and and then Alexa will
like play the posts here so something
like that and I'm gonna just start with
this here because this is probably going
to get us to where I was hoping to get
to today for day two so today we did the
recap and the we're gonna do the intro
to the s CLI while we're actually
building some functionality and the same
with the the ask SDK - so the the other
thing that I wanted to cover today is
getting data from an external API so
that will let us do that I think with
that example and we're going to use the
I found a NPM module that will let us
call out to medium so we'll I haven't
used it before but I think that will
that will cover us for today so the ask
CLI I think I touched on this really
quickly yesterday I did this example
scale I'm gonna just delete this start
all over and create
so in here the ask CLI like I mentioned
is a command-line tool and it lets you
create skilled projects which are local
projects and in case anybody's not
familiar with the IDE that I'm using
right now I mentioned this yesterday but
for anybody that's that you just come in
on this is Visual Studio code it's an
open source editor similar to like atom
which is another one so you can get this
for free for Windows Linux or Mac and
that's what I'm using so it's got an
integrated terminal so I'm running the
command line ask new here and then the
Alexus skills kit CLI prompts me for a
name and we're gonna call this free code
camp okay Alexis cool and when I do that
this CLI creates a folder and I'm gonna
walk through what's in the folder right
now and just kind of give you a
high-level tour of the stuff that we're
going to be starting with so I mentioned
yesterday that this is gonna be sort of
boilerplate code you can start working
with him and what's what the CLI is
doing is it's actually going out to a
github repository and pulling down
sample code so in addition to using the
basic basic template that is included
you can also do something like this
before I go in there you can go like ask
new template and when you do that the
CLI will prompt you or provide you with
a list of templates that Amazon provides
and I would um if you're getting into
this I would definitely recommend like
downloading these templates and taking a
look at it's a really great way to get
familiar with the code and most of them
are updated now with the I think they're
all updated actually now with the
SDK so the the code is pretty current
we're gonna start from scratch and just
use the basic one but the other option
you can scroll down there's there's a
bunch of templates in here so lots of
lots of stuff to dig into to to get
familiar with some some code examples we
also have I'll pick like how to just to
show you what happens so there's the
how-to and then we've also set up ask
new template you can also create your
own templates and we've got some that we
use at data lab at PS / / guild
templates / templates Jason and these
these mostly go with tutorials that I've
done on YouTube so they're not all
updated with the latest SDK but there is
a basic starter and a API starter there
that are updated so I'll start with like
the API starter just so you can see that
so now I've just gone through creating
three different skill templates so I did
that just to walk through the getting
the the ask CLI to give you a starting
point so three three different options
the the default one here is what we're
gonna be working with but I'll reference
code in these ones which is part of the
benefit of having the templates just you
can go back and look at code patterns
that you used previously and copy and
paste those to save your save you from
having to type everything out but in the
in each one of the skill project folders
I'm gonna
move into the folder there's there's a
dot ask folder Orlando folder a models
folder and then a skill dot Jason file
and in the ask folder is configuration
information for the ask CLI and when you
start with a brand new template the the
main thing is the URI here the the value
of the URI here for the end point this
is going to define the name of your
lambda function so when you publish the
skill it is gonna create the lambda
function for you out in the AWS Amazon
Web Services and this is where you can
change the name if you wanted it starts
with a default name that works fine the
lambda folder is gonna contain a
subfolder called custom by default and
then within the custom folder is
actually the source code for your lambda
function and you'll have your node
modules in there the SDK automatically
includes the the CLI rather
automatically includes the Alexus skills
kit SDK and the the SDK just makes
creating the responses more than
anything else makes creating the
responses and consuming the requests
from Alexa a lot easier so rather than
you having to write the code and end to
to do that yourself the skills kit is
gonna handle most of the heavy lifting
for you the the SDK is and this this
index file is by default where the where
the lambda function code is going to to
start I got a question yesterday about
whether or not most of the examples
you'll see all of the code is and the
functions and everything are just in one
file this index file does it need to be
like that and the answer's no you can
use node modules and you can create
custom modules and you can do you know
all of the stuff that you could do in
node if if you're familiar with that if
if not or
you want to keep it simple you can also
just put it all in in one file I think
probably for our example we'll break it
up a little bit just to show some
examples of using node modules so will
will get will go a little bit beyond
just keeping it super simple but in here
what you what you really want to take
note of is these functions here or
actually these these objects with
functions that have been specifically
they can't handle and handle so this is
new to the 2.0 SDK but the that can
handle function here it's going to be so
the Jason the request input gets passed
in here and it's going to look at the
request to determine what the request
type is and there's an intent request
which is when I talked yesterday about
the interaction model I said that the
intense kind of mapped to functionality
that the skills going to provide the
intent that we define in the model if
it's a user-defined custom intent or
actually if it's a built-in intent
there's going to be a name for the
intent and so we first looked to see if
it is an intent request versus like a
request for just launching the skill for
the first time which is here's an
example that the launch request so in
this code here when the user says Alexa
open whatever the skill name is in this
case here the response is going to be
welcome to the Alexa skills kit you can
say hello and when the user says hello
which is a segue into the models which
I'll get to in a second the skill
service this one anyway says hello world
back so it's a really simple starting
point and handle some of the
tired intense like when a user says stop
or cancel and so we'll use this as as
our starting point also the model when
we yesterday when we went through and we
looked at setting up the interaction
model through the developer console we
talked about the the model being just
Jason this is that model also so we can
define all of that in here and what
you'll see today is that we'll be able
to do everything from our local IDE
without ever having to go into the web
browser and log into developer David's
NomCom I will do that I'll log in just
to show you the the updates but when
you're working on your your your
development flow you probably won't be
logging into the developer council all
that much the CLI doesn't just let you
deploy the the skills and and update the
skills but you can also test from the
CLI to which we'll get into probably not
today but maybe tomorrow or the
following day Thursday and then the last
thing on our tour through the skilled
project is the the manifest file and the
manifest file is is going to define
settings and mostly configuration
information that you would find in the
developer console so when you log in
there and you create for example like a
name for the skill that is this here and
I'm gonna change this right now we're
going to just call this skill free code
camp and then we'll want a description
for the skill and anybody who wants to
join in on this I'll push this out to
github somewhere too so if anybody wants
to help and collaborate but if somebody
wants to take that is an action item and
come up with like a cool description for
this anybody volunteering
yeah I'll break it into some small files
with multi-turn dialogues did you come
up with the dialogue you come up with
the example just looking at it comments
what's the difference between angular
and react ooh
probably outside the scope of this this
stream here we're not going to be using
angular or react with this one okay so
so if somebody could take either you
know somebody on the the dadlab team or
probably somebody else that is is out
watching this that wants to wants to get
involved and come up with a description
for us we're gonna also in the model
we're gonna change the invocation name
and the invocation name remember from
yesterday is the name that the user is
going to use to start the scale-up
invoke it and we're going to call this
free free code camp so at this point all
I change was just the name and the
invocation name but let's um let's go
ahead and deploy it and to deploy the
skill you need to do that you know what
I'm also gonna change this actually I'm
gonna leave that that's fine so you need
to be in the folder in the project
folder to run this next command so one
of the questions there are the issues
that I see on the and the tutorials on
YouTube is if you try to run the command
actually let me do that so you can see
this so like right now I'm I'm just in
let's go here so now I'm just in the the
root folder called free code camp
livestream and if I try to run this
command here I'm gonna get an error
can't find skilled Jason and that's
because you've got to run that command
from the project folder that you're
working in so if I did whoops
camp Alexa skill so yeah so if I did
this now I can go ask deploy and when I
do that now the ask CLI is pushing the
skill out to the developer council for
me and it will once that's done it will
start building the interaction model and
then it will publish the the land of
function for us also so while that's
happening let's go over here and take a
look so I mentioned earlier that I
cleared everything out from yesterday so
now it's probably already deployed this
so I'm refreshing in there this now is
what the skills kit CLI deployed for us
from the tramline
what's a multi turned dialogue a multi
turned dialogue is a dialogue that is
going to request more information so
there's a back and forth something like
if a user if you had an intent for
example where a user was gonna order a
pizza you might need to know what size
pizza they want what toppings they want
and so the it's gonna be multi turn
means you're going to get a response
from Alexa that's gonna prompt you for
response back and then maybe a response
back again so rather than it just being
something simple like would at the top
medium posts it might be something like
you know what maybe you know what the
Alexa would ask what programming
language are you interested in and the
user might say I don't know what one
would you suggest and the skill might
say well how many
how many years of experience do you have
in tech I don't know something like that
but it would go back and forth before
the intent was fulfilled and the final
response was was sent back to the user
so hopefully that makes sense
all right so the the so we've got our
base kill here now let's let's go in and
test it so I mentioned yesterday that if
you set up your Alexa developer account
using the same email that you use if
you've got an echo then you can you can
test using your echo and so I've got
[Music]
show you this okay so we're gonna test
this now so Alexa open free code camp
okay
so you see on the screen there's also a
response here because I'm using an echo
show actually that will if you're using
an echo that doesn't have a screen that
what's showing on the screen will also
pop up in the companion app so if you've
got like an iOS or an Android device
with an echo you can use cards and
responses to post text stuff back can
also actually a lot of people use this
but if you you can also go to Alexa
amazon.com and log in with your account
to see this as well
sorry showing the wrong screen was doing
that so you can log into you Alexa dot
amazon.com as well and you can see we're
getting our cart response back there so
yes so what what's going on here like I
mentioned earlier is in this this
default skill we're getting the the
launch request we're just coming in here
and say welcome to the Alexa skills kit
you can say hello we're gonna change
this to our oops wait a second we have
that in your don'twe dialog we're going
to change this to this here and
and we're gonna change the one change
the the reap romped here and i think
we'll just do what will we say so the
read prompt happens if the user doesn't
respond after eight seconds so that
right now this change here when the user
launches the skill it'll say hello
welcome to the free code camp skill I
can tell you about recent median
articles or scheduled live streams what
would you like and if the user doesn't
respond we'll just say what would you
like alright and the this is the card
that showed up on the screen and we'll
just call this free code camp right now
and so this this hello world intent
handler so this is so right now if we
look at what we've got and we break that
into what the user wants we've got two
different possible intense right so
we've got if you look in here the user
could either want recent median articles
or they could want scheduled live
streams right so the intent is gonna map
to the functionality in most cases that
the skill is going to provide does that
make sense
yeah the toys toys are mine just I'm
gonna take one one second here to read
through some of the the questions and
comments and then I'm going to talk
about how you would create these
additional intents but let me just make
sure we're covered up to this point
yeah I think that multi-turn example
works we could use something like that
try to if you if you can try to try to
turn that into something that would make
sense for the the free code camp skill
so I don't just want to if if we can
avoid it I don't just want to do like a
hello world skill I'd love for the next
few days to end up with something
productive coming out of it other than
just having a chance to to work through
some of these examples together but I've
got tutorials where you can go through
that I'd love to work with everybody to
actually create a live skill I think
that would be fun so if you've got if
you've got some things that you want to
see if you can somehow come up with an
example where it would work for the free
code camp skill that would be ideal that
would be great so I am going to get back
to it here because we are about 40 40
minutes in and I want to try to make up
get as far as we can I'm just hoping to
get to actually making a request to a
remote API today so that that's my goal
let's see if we can do it so now I'm
gonna focus on just this this first
intent here which is the we'll call it
like the medium intent so when somebody
is going to request what articles recent
articles or we'll call it the recent
articles intent so right now we've got
this hello world Handler and I'm gonna
just I'll just copy this show you and
paste example here and I'm going to call
this one recent
I call it the recent articles intent and
so here what I what I need to do is I
need to look for the in the Jason what
the intent name is so if you recall from
yesterday when we're testing I'm gonna
go in here just to recap this because I
think it's important for understanding
what's happening in the code so when we
test here and so this is the request
that the Alexa service sent to our skill
service and if you look at the Jason
you'll see that in the Jason there is a
request type and this is session ended
request and so this is a launch request
you know because the session ended from
previously and that's why we're getting
this here if we want to to map this to
something that the user says we need to
update our model so that the Alexa
service knows that the user is asking
for a different intent and that's what
we're going to do right now so now we
have our and I'm going to call our new
intent
now call us a handler actually and we'll
just car intent recent articles intent
and so that's what we're gonna name it
and we'll stuff it out for right now in
the card I'll just have the title say
articles for right now okay so now what
we need to do is we need to map what the
user says to this intent and the way
that we're going to do that is in our
model and so in our model here we're
going to you can see this hello world
intent we're going to create a new
intent and we're gonna call it what did
we just call this like memories going
back like two seconds recent articles
so the recent articles intent and then
we need some samples of what the user
might say that would allow us to
identify that they want the the recent
articles intent and we can look at our
dialogue over here to see I can tell you
about median articles so maybe they say
what's been posted on medium start with
the one that we used for our example and
then we want we want to provide a few
examples so the the the machine learning
engine that is underpinning Alexa is
gonna learn from these examples so that
you don't have to come up with like
every possible thing that the user might
say but you need to provide enough
example so that the the Alexa service
can infer when a user says something
that's not provided explicitly in the
examples so maybe what's been posted on
medium will say any new medium posts and
just how about just medium posts and
then of course we'll test it to make
sure this works but that is going to I
think do it for the model let me just go
back here to make sure we've got
everything in here oh one other thing
that I didn't do is you've got to
register the intent handler also so down
here this add request handlers you've
got two for the SDK you've got to
include the well that's not the one new
article
nandu article oh my gosh did I just call
that recent article okay so now I think
we have everything that we need let's um
let's give it a try so now we're gonna
ask deploy again and if if I haven't
missed anything we should be able to to
go test this out how we doing on time
146 not sure if we'll get to pulling it
from median actually I think we will
still got 15 minutes that's plenty of
time
okay you see here this response back you
can actually test from the the CLI also
I'm not going to do that right now
because I want to spend a little bit of
time of that time on that later but
let's just try try a little exit here or
so let's see what happens
Alexa open free code camp what would
like median articles when this is done
I'll read back recent articles okay so
that seems to have worked I think I had
a typo in the dialogue
I heard which it's not a big deal but
I'll fix it hello welcome to the free
code camp skill I can tell you about
recent media articles probably probably
need to come there or scheduled live
streams what would you like alright okay
so now it's it's doing what it's
supposed to do actually let me show you
one more thing
Alexa open free code camp hello welcome
to the free code camp skill I can tell
you about recent medium articles or
scheduled live streams what would like
live streams when this is done I'll read
back recent articles okay
so what's happening right now is I don't
have enough examples to where Alexa
knows what to do with that so that isn't
what we want right we don't want when
somebody says live streams we don't want
Alexa to just dump them to whatever
seems to make sense based on the
examples so what we would want to do is
we would want to create another handler
for live streams and then also update
our model which actually we're going to
do that
now I'm gonna just change this okay so
now we've got this and remember we've
got to register it so I'm going to get
rid of the hello world and let's see so
I'm going through the exact same steps
here that we just went through and
stubbing out and we'll stop this out to
you okay
and what else do I need to do anybody
know anybody in comments we need to
update our model let's see I'm just
going to change this to recent articles
intent and I'll say like articles
I'll wait not streams live streams live
streams kill me scheduled live streams
and I think ice messed something up in
here there live streams intent handler
this should be live streams so this will
be for live streams live streams okay
let's um let's test this out so let me
just double check I think this is all
good so again we're going to deploy and
[Music]
while this is deploying let's um let's
take a look at how we're gonna try to
get the median feed in here so turn off
okay so I'm going to I've if you go to
media okay Karthik I see okay sorry I
forgot to switch screens there I think
that's what Karthik is trying to let me
let me know okay so let's take a look at
the median so on medium yeah I did
forget to switch back sorry about that
guys my brain is challenged with like
one operation at a time
so bear with me let's see so I think
it's free code camp right camp median
Wow yeah medium death free code camp
talk org okay so I was I was looking
through so there is a an API for an SDK
for medium and but it requires
authentication which I didn't have for
free code camp so what I am gonna do to
make this work is there is another node
module that I found that pulls the RSS
feed and then converts it to a adjacent
feed and I tested it like five minutes
before this live stream so let me show
you my test and then we're gonna
incorporate this into here about six
minutes to do it right so this is get me
a pose this is the this is the example
that I did earlier let me show you what
what's going to happen so
and the wrong folder here okay so what
what this is doing is returning back a
list of the latest posts and we're gonna
use that to try to read back the read
back that the titles of the post and
there's there's more work we're gonna
need to do tomorrow because this is
probably too many to just read back to
the user but we'll figure that out
tomorrow for right now let's just let's
go back in here and see what we would do
to change that or to wire this up rather
so in here the first thing we need is to
include the medium JSON feed and let's
save that
oops forgot install okay so I'm
installing that node module here and
then I'm going to just take this stuff
here and go into my skill and I am going
to use let's see where is our articles
handler here so I'm going to use a
feature of JavaScript a new feature so
lambda supports JavaScript 8.10 I think
is the latest one and so I can use async
in a way and the the details about that
there's plenty of courses on free code
camp that can get into that in more
detail so I'm not going to go in that
here right now just because we got just
a few minutes but I'm gonna do like a
sake and like this try
I run out of time here let's see and
then here I'm going to set this to just
one article for right now see if I can
do that I'll just do the first one right
now and I think it's still title if I've
messed something out then I'm gonna just
right now say okay so here's here's
what's happening I think if I haven't if
I haven't missed anything
now what should happen is we should go
out and fetch the feed of the latest
articles and then we're going to take
the most recent I don't need this we're
gonna take the the first item in that
feed and grab the title and write that
to our speech text so this this should
if it works it should write back the or
it should play speak back rather the the
title of the very first article so let's
let's let's give it a try
so ask sure let me get over here
ask employee and then there's also
switches that you can use and there's
one T so I'm what I'm gonna do for this
is I'm just deploying the lambda
function so - t is for target lambda and
this will deploy a lot faster I haven't
changed the interaction model or
anything of course that was the error
that I said comes up all the time and I
just did it okay okay so now if the demo
gods are live stream coding gods are
with us this'll work Alexa open free
code camp hello welcome to the free code
camp skill I can tell you about recent
medium articles or scheduled live
streams
what would my recent media articles
sorry I can't understand the command
please say it in media articles sorry I
can't understand the command
see okay we're gonna finish this up
tomorrow
Alexis cotton so we're gonna we're gonna
call it a day there I know I didn't get
a chance to look at all of the questions
but we'll be picking up from here
tomorrow so hopefully I will see all of
you back if you have any ideas between
today and tomorrow on what we can do for
this free code camp skill if you if you
provide some good ideas we'll make sure
that you get credit for your ideas and
make you part of the repo that github
repo so looking for contribution I'd
really like to see this actually get
used and deployed but needs to be more
than a demo to do that so any help would
be appreciated so that's it for today
guys I didn't quite get to to get the
feed working but I will pick that up
tomorrow at 1:00 1:00 p.m. Eastern so
same time and we'll continue on from
there so again I hope to see everybody
back I'm going to wrap it up for now
thanks so much for for attending and
hope to see you back tomorrow